- So Guemmy,
you're...
Which I agree with.
You're telling us to have
hard to break into passwords.
But then the obvious question is
how does a normal human being
manage all of these passwords,
that don't have regular words in them?
They can't reuse the same
password over and over.
How do we manage all of this?
- Yes, great question.
It is really hard to keep up with
all of the different services.
I don't know about you, but I
use over a hundred services,
and the only reason I know that,
(Sal and Guemmy laugh)
is actually because I've
used a password manager,
and seeing the list actually surprised me.
Password managers are great,
because they can automatically
save the passwords for you.
And they're super convenient,
because once you go back to a website,
not only do they check that
it's not like a phishing website
or somebody pretending to
be the legitimate website,
but they'll also conveniently
fill in your password for you,
and you just click a button.
And so it's super quick,
especially if you're on mobile.
It's been a lifesaver.
One thing that I've always
worried about password managers,
is sometimes I'm logging
in from my laptop,
sometimes from my phone,
sometimes from my wife's laptop,
will the password managers
work across multiple devices?
- Yeah, different password managers
definitely have different capabilities,
but at least on Google,
when you're signed into
your Google account,
on the various devices,
then yes, we can pull together
all of the information,
from that password manager,
and display it on the different
devices that you're using.
- And how do you compare
a password manager,
which can kind of store all
of these things locally,
and be able to fill in when you need it,
and keep track of it.
To being able to use a service.
You know, obviously Google
has it, you have Apple,
You have other folks,
who have once you sign into that account,
that allows you to sign
into other accounts.
Do you recommend both?
How do you compare those two things?
- I think it's up to the user's choice,
and so sometimes users
are going to be limited
because of what the
website developer has done.
For example, not all websites
offer the sign in with Google,
with Apple, sign in with
Facebook, et cetera.
But all websites do have passwords,
and so at a minimum you can
always have your own username,
and password for that service,
and then store it in the password manager.
Alternatively, if you don't wanna create,
a bunch of new accounts
all over the internet,
you could definitely use your
Google account for instance,
and sign in into various services
using your Google account.
I personally like that option
because it actually reduces the
number of different accounts
I have to worry about.
And I mean of course Google is backed
by the strongest security,
among the strongest in the industry,
so it's something that I feel good about.
- Thanks for that Guemmy.